hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter 9 of book 3 of his work on
anger Seneca is going to attend very
closely to what we nowadays call the
Mind Body Connection we are physical
beings and we do have you know whatever
you want to call it a psychical a mental
life as well but they're not totally
dissociated from each other the Mind
does in fact in at least in some
respects rule the body but the body and
its stresses it's getting tired it's
various arrangements and humors whatever
we want to call it certainly affects the
mind and so there are some things that
Seneca thinks somebody who's inclined to
anger needs to really attend to so that
they don't get angry uh you know you
might even say they don't trigger their
anger
by allowing themselves to feel lousy or
bad in other respects physically and
that then affecting the mind and he
begins by talking about something that
we might say well that's not really
physical as such but it certainly could
be it says people inclined to anger
should give up unusually demanding
fields of study studio
graviora right these serious demanding
things that we could be devoting
ourselves to and he'll give some
examples of this a little bit further
down he says we ought to avoid the Forum
advocacy the courts and all Pursuits
that irritate the vice of anger now
going to the court that's adversarial
The Forum likewise that's probably going
to be not just physically demanding and
psychologically stressful but you're
already in a position where you're
engaging with other people in ways that
are antagonistic right so it's easy for
anger to arise but there might be other
things that we could study and you know
it might be something that we're not
particularly good at and we have to
apply ourselves very hard and we get
frustrated because it's placing these
demands we don't understand things and
then we we get angry or it could just be
that by its very nature even if we are
good at it it is in fact quite demanding
and it's interesting that Seneca a
little bit later will use the example of
music because you know depending on how
you're studying it and what sort of
instrument you're working on that could
actually be a physically demanding or
mentally demanding field of study and so
Seneca says they should either give up
these fields of study or don't pursue
them to the point of exhaustion so maybe
you could
put it out you know in in bits and
pieces drips and drabs as we say you
allot yourself an hour a day rather than
spending the entire day on some
difficult subject or you build up to it
right so that's some interesting advice
right there what should we do instead he
says their minds shouldn't be employed
on hard subjects but should be entrusted
to the pleasant Arts and he says let
them be soothed by breeding poetry and
beguiled by legends from history the
goal is a softer and more comfortable
mental regimen right molius which is the
softer part and a delicatius Quay right
a more comfortable more suited to
ourselves this isn't to say that we
can't ever approach hard topics but you
get the idea with Seneca if you're
somebody who's irritable you need to
proportionate you need to measure it you
need there needs to be times of
relaxation as well as times of intensive
study and then he does talk about
music as an example he brings up
Pythagoras Pythagoras used to play the
liar to settle his mind when it was
upset and so playing the liar if you
don't know what that is it's a stringed
instrument and generally you weren't
playing more than one string at a time
back then and it might be nice soft
um you know little melodies or arpeggios
or whatever it is that you're going to
play and notice that he says that
Pythagoras would play and you know we
have other interesting examples of
philosophers who used music you know I
think of for example of Thomas Hobbes
much much much later in time in the
modern era whose exercise was singing
exercising his lungs uh singing songs
now you could also do that in order to
calm your mind right depending on what
the music is he will contrast this
against
um
other kinds of music and he brings up
War horns and trumpets specifically you
know the martial music that is supposed
to get people all riled up and if you
think about today's contemporary music
it probably depends significantly on the
person I remember as a teenager and a
young adult hearing because I was a
metal head I was into classic have a
heavy metal from the 70s and 80s hearing
all that such angry music it's going to
make you an angrier person and
interestingly we find out with studies
that people who are really into metal
are often calmed by it whereas other
people perceive it as
riling them up as frustrating or
something like that but we might say
that about many other genres of music as
well what's going to be calming for you
won't necessarily be the softest stuff
but Seneca is advocating that he says
certain beguiling songs are conducive to
mental relaxation
so whatever the music is going to be
it's still the same point there's a
mind-body connection and some kinds of
music might make us angrier other kinds
of music might make us calmer and it's
up to us to figure out what those are so
that we can actually listen to the right
sort of music to calm ourselves down
he also very interestingly talks about
colors and he mentions specifically
green looking at Green objects helps
when our vision is all a jumble and then
it goes on and says some colors calm our
glance when it's unsteady just as the
brightness of some others dazzles it
right and he's going to draw a
connection here to studies of things
some studies give that give Pleasures
through their capacity for thought when
it's sickly but coming back to the color
issue maybe what we need to do is have
color schemes for you know our
decorations what we're wearing we could
even like deliberately look at certain
images to calm ourselves down maybe
getting out there since we're talking
about greenness in nature if there is
some greenness and it's not all dry and
drab although you know that can have its
own charm as well maybe that can have a
calming effect on our body and our mind
then he talks about physical exhaustion
and he's got some very interesting
things to say about this right so the
the Latin there is lassitudin M corporis
right a a tiredness an exhaustion of the
body we should avoid this why he says
that
it uses up whatever is mild and calm
meta placidum Quay
and it Rouses what is fierce in us and
then he goes on and he says something
about bile now this this has to do with
uh ancient theory of the humerus anger
and irritation was associated with black
bile menoncolas right so the idea was
you want to have less of that if you eat
maybe you can reduce that physical
exertion and other stresses on the
system tend to promote this so he says
that that's the reason why people whose
temper is unreliable they take some food
to balance their bile when they're about
to undertake matters of Greater moment
becoming wearied stirs up bile and then
he gives you a few ideas about why this
might be the case none of which are
particularly a important because we've
you know when it comes to Medicine we
don't really think in these terms
anymore but let's look at what he says
he tells us either because it forces all
bodily heat into the middle regions
damages the blood and stops the
circulation because the veins become
overtaxed or because the body when it's
weakened and unsteady presses its weight
on the mind and he says that's why
people worn out by disease or age are
more inclined to anger now you know we
don't really buy into these physical
explanations anymore but we have plenty
of others right we're being flooded with
cortisol or you know uh the the
this balance in not our bodily humors
but in blood flow and hormones and
things like that is disrupting us as
well right we can go on and on and on
with physical explanations
the main point that Seneca wants to make
here is whatever is the causal medical
explanation physical exhaustion can make
us much more liable to getting angry and
we could also add to this a lack of
sleep will often make people quite
irritable and I like this idea of it
uses up what is mild and calm within us
right
so you know becoming weird
fatigatio stirs up this bile stirs up
whatever it is in us that gets us
more likely to respond in angry ways and
then he talks about hunger and thirst
now this is a very interesting one he
says we should also avoid hunger and
thirst for the same reasons what do they
do they irritate exasperat and inflame
in Cadet our minds that literally they
make our minds on fire they they start a
fire they start a spark in our minds and
so he says there's an old saying a tired
man goes looking for a fight and that's
equally true of a Hungry Man a thirsty
man any man who's galled by anything it
might be somebody who's in chronic pain
right he says just as sores hurt at a
slight touch and even the mere thought
of a touch
to the extent so a mind that's impaired
is offended for the slightest reasons to
the extent that they're greeting a
letter of speech a question provokes
some people to quarrel whatever sickly
squawks when it's touched so you know
hunger and thirst if we are in a uh
condition where we you know skipped
launched skipped breakfast uh were
dehydrated we're not getting what we
need we're more likely to get irritated
and if we're already people liable to
anger to go down the path to anger the
things that would normally not tick us
off like he says you know a greeting
somebody greets you how you doing
you don't care how I'm doing right we
could go on a letter a speech a question
it's not that the person is really angry
at that it's rather that they have this
you know physical irritant and it makes
it so much easier for them to feel anger
so all of these things to some degree at
least chronic pain may be a bit more
difficult to deal with all these things
are you know to some degree in our
control obviously a lot of people don't
have that much choice about the kind of
work that they have to pursue through
the day and that might make them angry
but many of us actually do have quite a
bit of uh you know control and ability
to prioritize what we're going to do we
can listen to certain music or look at
certain colors we can try to avoid
physical exhaustion as much as possible
or being overly hungry or thirsty not
just at meal times or when we're going
to take a a little water break or
something along those lines these things
if we pay attention to them and we don't
treat our body as if it's just a
Workhorse for our mind to do whatever
the hell it wants with
if we attend to our body we can keep
ourselves from lapsing so easily into
anger